I'm David Hibbett professor of mycology
I'm here to answer your questions from
Twitter this is mushroom support
[Music]
okay first up from Nicole semino3 who
says why do mushrooms have to look like
that I'm trying to enjoy them but their
physique makes me uncomfortable a
mushroom has one function and that is to
liberate spores the shapes of mushrooms
that have evolved through natural
selection have been optimized for Spore
dispersal so a Spore is a cell that's
designed to be disseminated to be
distributed by wind or water or insects
or some other means a bracket fungus
like this might produce a billion spores
a day a giant puff ball can produce
literally trillions of spores and an
awful lot of mushrooms have a shape like
this with a cap and a stalk maybe gills
underneath maybe pores maybe teeth and
that tells us that this must be the
right shape for a mushroom this must
work really well for Spore dispersal
most spores don't make it they don't end
up germinating and forming a new fungus
but the fungus makes many many sports in
order to maximize its chances of
reproducing successfully Sheila crimmins
asks what's the difference between
cremini button and portobello mushrooms
well the difference is really just a
matter of age because all of these types
of commercial mushrooms are the same
species agaricus by spores they're all
the same thing they're just harvested at
different stages of the life cycle the
classic little white button mushroom
with the closed cap is harvested very
early in its life before the cap is
started to open before the spores are
mature so the gills are going to be just
a pale pink and not particularly
flavorful cremini mushrooms are
harvested a little bit later on they
started to turn brown develop some
pigmentation the cap has started to open
started to turn brown as the spores have
matured and the portabellas are the
fully mature agaricus by spores the cap
has opened up it become kind of
flattened out the veils that conceal the
gills as they develop have broken away
and the gills have that beautiful dark
brown chocolate color and they've also
started to develop a lot more flavor
Fabrice singer asks a carnivorous
mushroom how scary is that so first of
all yes there are carnivorous mushrooms
in fact this this innocent looking
fungus the oyster mushroom is a
carnivore it's also a wood Decay fungus
this naturally grows in nature on tree
trunks but this fungus also is able to
trap kill and consume tiny warm-like
animals called nematodes and it does
this at the level of the mycelium this
fungus produces tiny little
protuberances off the sides of the
hyphae microscopic little projections
from which it secretes a droplet of
fluid and that fluid contains a potent
neurotoxin when the nematode this tiny
little worm-like animal comes in contact
with that neurotoxin it's esophagus it's
its throat basically you can see it
contort and then the fungus grows into
that nematode and digests it from the
inside out fuzzy semi asks why did
mushrooms evolve to have psychedelic
properties you shouldn't assume that
magic mushrooms evolve to have
hallucinogenic properties for the
benefit of humans in fact magic
mushrooms probably don't care about
humans at all lots of fungi and plants
for that matter produce chemicals whose
primary function is to deter grazers in
the case of psilocybin mushrooms I've
heard an idea suggested recently that
psilocybin may actually interfere with
the digestion of slugs slugs are major
grazers on mushrooms so if that is true
then it is just a happy accident of
evolution that we can get high feeding
on what is essentially slug poison okay
now we have something from the fun bit
project how do mushrooms defend
themselves defend themselves against
what I mean the way that mushrooms
defend themselves from animals that
would like to eat them is by producing
chemicals called secondary metabolites
that effectively act as poisons fungi
also need to defend themselves against
other fungi you can see this in a
culture in the laboratory on auger you
can also see it if you take a slice
through a log that's been colonized by
multiple species of fungi and you'll see
these dark black interaction lines
that's what spalted wood is which is
very highly prized by Woodworkers
because the fungi in the process of
fighting over Turf make beautiful
patterns from those interaction Zone
lines in Wood the next question comes
from femdom Farm do you happen to know
if there are any major differences
between mushrooms that grow on wood dead
or living versus mushrooms that grow
from the ground so if a mushroom is
growing out of a log it's a pretty good
bet that that's a wood Decay fungus
right if a mushroom is growing out of
the ground it might also be decaying
dead organic matter that's in the soil
like buried roots or wood or something
but it could also be mycorrhizal so
mycorrhizal fungi grow in partnership
with trees the fungi deliver mineral
nutrients to the trees and in return the
trees provide sugars which they make
through photosynthesis to the fungus LM
King asks how do zombie ants become
zombies I'm going to push back on this
question just a little bit because I
think it's a misuse of the word zombie
zombie ant fungi do not reanimate ant
corpses they're what we call necrotrophs
they're fungi they that can infect kill
and then eat another organism an ant in
the case of the zombie ant fungi but
when the zombie ants are dead they are
truly dead and they are not coming back
rhcm123 asks could a parasitic fungus
evolve to control humans if you're
asking could cordyceps or one of its
relatives make the jump from an insect
to a human and control us and kill us
I'm not terribly worried about that
myself because our biology is so wildly
different from that of arthropods like
insects and so on now it's true that the
group of fungi that include the zombie
ant fungi have made lots of host jumps
but most of those are host jumps to
other kinds of insects like onto cicadas
or grasshoppers or moth larvae or
something like that there are other
fungi that I am worried about however
there's something called Candida Oris
which is a yeast related to the yeast
that we make beer and wine from and this
is an emerging pathogen that is drug
resistant that crops up in lots of
Hospital settings and it's a very
serious concerned but I'm not afraid of
cordyceps I'm tired y'all says do any of
you grow mushrooms at home how with a
cultivation kit is it worth it any tips
slash advice slash recommendations it's
tremendous fun growing mushrooms it's
kind of miraculous to watch them emerge
from a block of sawdust if you buy one
of the commercial kits they make it very
easy because what you get is a fully
colonized block of substrate which is
usually based on Sawdust and you just
have to set it up and the mushrooms will
come the challenge is providing the
right environment for the mushrooms and
the Big Challenge there is humidity
mushrooms like about 90 to 95 percent
humidity in order to fruit optimally
Luke greensmith asks fungus is never not
nightmare fuel why is it neither plant
nor animal let's just take a step back
and point out that not all of life is
plants or animals that's a really old
idea fungi are on this branch of the
Tree of Life called the apisticons which
also contains animals plants are very
far away in a group that's called the
archiplasty that also includes algae and
so on Plants also obviously have
chloroplasts they can do photosynthesis
and that's something that both fungi and
animals cannot do so this plants versus
animals dichotomy is something that is
very old and that we're still working
hard to try to overcome next question is
from Hank Green sometimes I think it
would be nice to be able to focus on a
single thing but other times I think
what's the biggest mushroom there are
some really big mushrooms out there but
the largest mushrooms are wood decaying
fungi that grow on massive substrates
like trunks of trees so for example
here's a wood Decay fungus called
Ganoderma aplanatum it's also called the
artist's conch and it grows on Tree
Trunks and it gets quite big here's
another similar one this is called
felinus tremulae or the Aspen bracket so
these are pretty big but these are
nowhere near a fruiting body of a
mushroom called phelanus ellipsoidius
that's 35 feet long and it was
discovered on an island in China on
Hainan island and it can get that big
because it's feed eating on a very
massive persistent Woody substrate that
it can eat and fruit from over many
years so pseudonym Jones says I really
like veiled lady mushrooms because
they're pretty and also alien looking
but mainly because scientists are like
cool right no idea why it does that the
veiled lady mushroom goes by a number of
names sometimes it's called veiled
stinkhorn the bridal veil mushroom the
bamboo mushroom the scientific name is
phallus enthusiatus so the species name
enthusiatus refers to a skirt or a tunic
and these fungi make a beautiful
lace-like veil-like structure that hangs
down from the fruiting body we have a
pretty good idea for why it looks the
way it does and that is to attract
insects most mushrooms release their
spores into the air and they drift off
on the wind and hopefully land somewhere
where they're going to germinate grow
find a good habitat and eventually make
more mushrooms stink horns exploit
insects to disperse their spores the
veil of that veiled lady must be a
visual attractant for Spore dispersing
insects and then on the head of the
fruiting body the fungus produces a
brown slimy fluid called the glieba that
contains the spores and which smells
like feces or decaying meat it's pretty
repulsive but if you're a fly or a
carrion beetle or something you'll find
it very attractive Lou talks about
nature asks spooky what's the weirdest
Mushroom in your opinion for my money
the spookiest mushroom is something
that's called hiddenellum peckiae and
the common name for this is the bleeding
tooth what really makes this thing
interesting is that it exudes droplets
of fluid on the top of the fruiting body
that are bright red so this is a toothed
mushroom that looks like it is dripping
oozing blood bear Doro says how can you
tell if a mushroom is poisonous or not
well sorry bear Doro but there is no
simple foolproof universal test to tell
whether or not a fungus is poisonous or
not you just have to know what you're
dealing with and it's really hard to
learn how to identify mushrooms from say
a book or from websites the best way to
learn how to ID mushrooms is to connect
with somebody who's good at mushroom ID
and get them to take you out in the
woods and teach you a few edible
mushrooms okay we have one now from my
real name who says mushrooms have 50 000
Sexes how many genders most mushrooms
like the ones in front of me here have
two different mating genes and in order
for mushrooms to be mating compatible
they have to have different variants of
those genes we call those alleles so the
number of sexes so to speak is
determined by the number of variant
alleles of each of those mating genes
the most famous Mushroom in which this
process has been studied is something
called the common split Gill or
schizophilum commune this fungus can
produce 28 000 unique Sexes so fungi are
non-binary in the extreme and the
concept of gender has absolutely no
applicability in fungi at all Grace Hall
313 says how am I supposed to believe my
biology teacher when she tells me that
humans and mushrooms are closely related
well first of all everybody knows that
biology teachers are among the most
honest and trustworthy people on the
planet and in this case she's right so
humans and mushrooms and other fungi and
other animals are all in a branch of the
tree of life that's called the
apistocots so when your biology teacher
tells you that mushrooms and humans are
more closely related to each other than
either is to plants she's got it
absolutely right so you should believe
everything she says from now on Mao
cdh13 who says what part of the mushroom
are the spores I'm so disgusted well
first of all I don't know why you find
spores disgusting I find them beautiful
especially under the microscope the
spores are produced on the underside of
the mushroom fruiting body on the gills
or in pores individually you can't see
them they're microscopic but in Mass you
can see them so sometimes mycologists
make what's called a Spore print where
you turn a mushroom upside down and put
it on a piece of paper and then you can
see the color of the spores when they're
deposited in huge numbers now we have
something from sassy gay root who says
what is the damn mycelium and what does
it do you can think of it as like the
vegetative body of the fungus and it's
really quite a miraculous structure it's
composed of millions of tiny microscopic
thread-like filaments that mycologists
call hyphy and they radiate out into the
substrate that the fungus is growing
through the substrate could be soil wood
a loaf of bread in your kitchen your
toenail this is the part of the fungus
that explores its environment captures
territory captures resources fights with
other fungi and mates so the mycelium is
really quite an amazing and important
phase in the life cycle of a fungus our
sock publishing which is Royal Society
publishing asks can mushrooms talk to
each other it depends on what you mean
by talk so obviously mushrooms do not
vocalize but they do communicate in some
way and they communicate biochemically
so when mushrooms bump into each other
when the Mycelia of two different
mushrooms interact they have to figure
out who they're dealing with maybe
they're bumping into another member of
their own species with whom they might
like to mate or they're bumping into a
different species and they're going to
fight with that other individual and so
they're going to exchange biochemical
signals and recognize self
non-self-mating compatible not made
incompatible I don't know if you
consider that talking but they certainly
do exchange information biochemically to
determine who they're dealing with
pneumocia says there are bioluminescent
mushrooms yes there are bioluminescent
mushrooms and they are totally cool we
have come to understand a lot about the
biochemistry of how they produce that
light it's an enzymatic reaction that
does it a more mysterious question is
why they do it it could just be a
metabolic byproduct it could have no
function at all but there have been at
least a couple of studies that have
suggested that in some cases that light
might actually help to attract insects
that might carry off the spores legalize
shroom one has two questions why am I in
this tyrannical police state called the
U.S and why why do magic mushrooms grow
on cow poop so I cannot help you with
the first question but for the second
one I will say that there are lots of
fungi that grow on animal dung we call
those coprophilus fungi so dung loving
fungi dung turns out to be a really
nutritious substrate for a fungus it's
got lots of nitrogen compounds it's got
sugars it's got carbohydrates it's a
great place to be a coprophilus fungus
Rosie Boyd asks why do mushrooms grow in
circles that is so cute we call
that a fairy ring and in the olden days
people thought that fairy rings
represented places where the fairies or
the elves had been dancing and people
were nervous to step into the middle of
a fairy circle now we know that the
reason that mushrooms often fruit in a
circle like that is because of the
structure of the mycelium so the
mycelium that network of filaments that
makes up the vegetative body of the
fungus all other things being equal in a
uniform environment will grow out in a
circle and that's how you get a fairy
ring that's how you get that circular
arrangement of mushrooms bread jimin 201
how many species of mushrooms are there
you know we've been studying fungi for
centuries and you would think that by
now we would know how many species of
fungi there are on the planet but we
don't so most of the mushroom forming
fungi are in a group that's called the
agaricomycetes and there's about 30 or
000 described species of agaricomycetes
but if you look at all of the fungi
together including molds yeasts mildews
plant pathogens and so on there's about
145 000 described species the number of
species that actually exists on Earth is
certainly much much larger some people
think that there might even be as many
as 165 million species of fungi on the
planet so what that means is that if
you're interested in mycology it's a
great field to make lots of new
discoveries and for me that's very
exciting Todd G Baker asks mowed my
grass yesterday evening this morning
this lone mushroom had appeared how can
anything grow so fast the answer is that
some mushrooms can grow very rapidly by
absorbing water and inflating their
cells probably when he mowed his lawn
the primordia the little structures that
are going to give rise of the fungus
we're already there waiting for the
right conditions to absorb water and
push up a mushroom so now we have
something from learning with Ms a who
says our science wondering question
today how do mushrooms decompose organic
matter can they decompose inorganic
matter when you say organic matter I
assume that you're talking about
something like wood leaf litter or
something like that fungi decompose that
kind of organic matter by growing into
it with their High fees those filaments
that make up the mycelium and they
release digestive enzymes into the
material they're going through digest
the organic matter around it and then
absorb the small molecules that are the
breakdown products of that digestion and
that's not terribly different from what
we do except that we digest our food
inside our bodies whereas fungi digests
their food outside their filaments with
these secreted enzymes two a scientist
organic compounds are just carbon-based
compounds including a lot of things that
you might not think of as organic
including coal oil various petroleum
products like Plastics and also some
pesticides polycyclic aromatic
hydrocarbons which can be very nasty
pollutants in the environment and some
fungi in particular white rot fungi
which are a kind of fungi that decay
would have been shown to be able to
break down those kinds of Organo
pollutants at least in the lab and
that's driven a lot of interest in
what's called micro remediation the
possibility that we could use fungi in
the environment to clean up some of the
messes that humans have left behind
Sushi Fox Zero says why is everyone
obsessed with mushrooms all of a sudden
is there something I'm missing everybody
should be obsessed with mushrooms
mushrooms are incredibly beautiful
incredibly diverse they play critical
roles in the ecosystem some of them are
delicious some of them are deadly some
of them are hallucinogenic and another
great reason to be interested in
mushrooms is because of the people the
huge community of amateur mycologists
and Community scientists who get
together and form mushroom clubs and go
out and do forays and grow mushrooms and
they're eager to share what they know
you should join a local mushroom club
and there are dozens of them all over
North America and then you too can
become obsessed with fungi okay that's
all the questions hope you learned
something thank you for watching until
next time